hello everyone Perry back with another
Sundance Collider interview brought to
you by Kia Telluride a huge thanks to
them we love covering movies here and
they are letting us talk to you the
filmmakers of Abe right now very excited
to be sitting with you guys I have a
million questions so I'm going to jump
right in here and ask you I tell this
particular story I think we are living
in a tough world where people are
divided all over and I think it's
important to bring people together and
food is an excellent vehicle for that
because every time you are in a fight
and you have a meal Kumu with someone
like changing your mindset and also I
think it's hard so it's hard to exist
hard to be a teenager and in social
media world even harder so tell the
story about this kid who is struggling
to find who is in our age in such a
complex background was something that
moved me to shine some light I am no
stranger to the idea of food bringing
people together but I was also looking
at your IMDB page and I know you have a
documentary in the works called the
flavors of Abraham and you said
coexistence through gastronomy so can
you explain for our viewers specifically
what that is yes I was like I felt it
was irresponsible to do this film
without researching Jerusalem and the
Middle East in person so just after I
met Noah I fly with my production
designer who directed this with me it
was not ready yet where he went through
Jerusalem and talked to many owners of
restaurants we made a bakery from
Palestine that was there for 300 years
his family we went to families we went
to a interfaith meeting with Jewish and
Muslim on a finished Church so just make
sure that we can make this as authentic
as possible to to the audience Noah did
you have any interesting cooking before
you signed on for this one I mean I've
always loved cooking and I always
thought it was cool and fun
and but I mean I wasn't as I feel like
I've improved with cooking since I did
this movie and even preparing for the
role before we started I took little
cooking classes learning like knife
skills with dicing and and even just
cracking eggs and learning like what
foods go well with what and and I I
learned a lot just about food and
cooking that I could take just into the
real world as a person after the movie
and I mean I've I I think I could say
I've become a better chef because of it
it's like a running joke on Collider
that everybody knows that I don't cook
anything like I've made my microwave or
it's a problem cereals fine but like I
can't cook anything so
okay I can use a toaster I can use a
toaster in a microwave but the second
the oven is involved or like chopping
something what if you like chicken I'm
afraid to cook the chicken I don't give
you classes later I would do anything
for a couple of pointers especially
something you learned on this movie that
maybe you didn't expect that really
helped you ah well I've learned like
with how to I mean I can't really show
it because I don't have a knife but how
do I I learned like I was always holding
a knife wrong and if like the way I used
to do it I had like a better chance of
like cutting myself and cutting a finger
and now you have to do like like three
like fingers like that and then like and
then like move the fingers back as
you're cutting interesting the only
thing I use the knives of my knife clock
for our opening my packages I know I
hope I it
I mean it takes a lot of time and care
and you got to put the effort into
actually learning the yeah but like a
chicken you just to used you put some
seasoning on it you throw it on the Sun
on the stove flip it all done I'll try
it if I give myself food poisoning
though can I blame you
yes in the spirit of the movie if you
had to pick two different cuisines to
blend together what would you choose and
why
well the the whole movie is like about
fusion and mixing different foods and
cultures together I think for me
personally as a person I love Italian
food and I love I love like tacos and
Mexican food and I think the coolest
thing would be to see like a some mix
between like pizza or pasta and a taco
something like like it like in the movie
like a ramen taco
yeah I feel like it's there's a you
there's so much you can do with the taco
and mixing other foods in in a taco and
I would love to see that sold I would
definitely have that similarly when you
go to a movie what is your favorite
concession stand item and then if there
was anything else you can introduce to
the concession stand what would it be
well I mean popcorn obviously no but I
don't know I don't love popcorn like I
think I eat too much and then I get a
stomach ache I I love M&Ms I think those
are great solid choice right there and
then if I could bring anything in but
there's already so much what is it like
a good something like really fancy that
like you like sushi or something sorry I
would be open to sushi I've also grown
obsessed with acai bowls it's also quiet
eating too well if you if you're gonna
have a dinner when I do a nice soup -
like sip on I'm totally sold on all this
I wouldn't mind having more options as a
Brazilian thank you for liking us a and
pronouncing it correctly - I feel like
I'm surprised that's still in is there
something you should have been where
this cool acai doesn't have what an ass
Europe because like pretending something
healthy but it's full of sugar Guarin
our syrup something from that's totally
like when you go somewhere and they're
scooping the acai out of an ice cream
tin rather than eating healthy but not
really so you need to check that what's
behind that's part of the s I know is
they used to make it
to it because usually the acai is not
sweet so you can sweet on different ways
with granola with honey with bananas or
agave but usually too big to be two
people buy more and be more active they
use this syrup that is super sweet so
figure 18 healthy and you're not and
you're not yeah that's the big problem
there but how do you I guess
not even just eat healthy but what what
do you have kind of in your bag as you
go around Sundance - because you're
running around doing a million
interviews you have screenings of your
movies so what do you have on you to get
through the festival well well first I
just had a really good trail mix I know
it was very very good and I feel like
that's a perfect maybe not like a Utah
food a trail I see how you're connecting
the dots here it makes it also for lunch
I had an amazing lunch at this place
called John and Vinny's or it was like a
pop-up and they had amazing meatballs so
that that really okay I'm into it how
about you shakes I like something you
have here in us that we don't have in
Brazil which is be milk nope oh my god
I'm pronouncing wrongly yeah right
different kind of milk
no yes Ward and sing something else Ward
that he said it's a milk chocolate and
it's really good so there's some words
that is like we start getting nervous
when you pronounce to say the X such
thing as P milk yes it's amazing it's
very important yeah but it's amazing
like almond milk yeah I'm big into the
almond milk I also wanted to ask you as
we were talking about before about your
background at Sundance which I find
really interesting so this this is your
first feature here first narrative
feature you were at Sundance though last
year so can you tell me a little bit
about the journey from that experience
to this yes I'm also I am also a
youtuber and I also write for Brazil
newspaper fall it's some Paulo so last
year I was here to cover the fastball
for folio and I have a media outlet in
Brazil for Human Rights coca brands to
Bruce was doing content portfolio cable
taboo and my youtube channel and was
amazing opportunity not only to
interview directors to see the behind
the scenes of the festival or to see how
hard journalists work with no I thought
only that makers don't sleep but I said
journalist you are in the same page
talking to someone who's going to a
midnight movie tomorrow and then getting
up at 7 o'clock tomorrow morning and I
love it every single second of it is
there anything from the interview
circuit last year that you kind of kept
in your back pocket for being
interviewed for your own movie this year
oh one interesting thing that I did was
they have the specific times that you
can talk with directors and etc but if
you just film the Q&A it's much more
spontaneous and you have the audience
and nobody's thinking there are fuming
so they're more natural and wax and
wearing masks
I know is this your first Sundance it's
my first Sundance yes but I've been to a
few years ago I did the Sundance labs
like the workshop and that was that was
such an amazing experience I got to meet
Robert Redford I had lunch with him and
I got to live in a little like cabin on
the mountain and be in Sundance for a
month it was I feel like if I ever had
lunch with Robert Redford I would just
sit there and kind of play with my food
yeah a little but I got through it did
anyone give you any pointers for having
the best Sundance experience you could
from well they all told me they were all
everyone there was all like they've been
there like 20 times and they were all
like very used to it and they all just
said they were all like oh have you ever
been to the festival and I'm like no and
everyone was like oh you're missing out
it's it's a really exciting experience
so now I'm excited to see like how it
all is do you get to see any other
movies while you're here I don't think
so but I mean I'm very excited to see
what I've been waiting to see for so
long and what does it mean to you guys
to have a butt showing at the festival
because when I look at a movie like this
first of all Sundance bring
movies to an audience that might not be
able to see them without the festival
circuit but in particular is about
someone just embracing their identity
who they are and their passion so in
your own words why are you excited to
bring Abe to moviegoers out there I'm
excited
especially because we got into Sundance
that's just such a I mean who would have
expected that that this movie it's it's
incredible and we're so lucky and I'm so
grateful to be able to be here I never
thought I would be able to to come to
the actual festival and now I'm here so
I'm just I'm very lucky and happy and
excited for everything oh I think this
Sundance is much more than a festival I
think it's a sacred place to incubate
ideas dreams and give voice for people
who not be willing to tell the stories
don't have the to to tell stories but
also situations and and people who
doesn't have the opportunity to be
represented on camera this the festival
has a very serious mission to represent
LGBTQ few makers and actors woman's
indigenous people so I think this is
super cool I always dream of being
sentenced almost all my films were
rejected before this so when I got the
news I got totally happy and blown away
and especially because they put in the
kids category and when I wrote the film
together with my writers I was thinking
like a live-action Pixar movie but as we
develop the story there was a scene with
marijuana another scene of alcohol so I
I kind of forget this but once Sundance
put on the kids category I see that we
made a film for the family an
opportunity for parents to bring their
kids to the cinema and not only feel
good not only cry and laugh but also has
a big a nice conversation about tough
subjects beautifully said thank you for
sharing that and thank you guys so much
for being here
another thank you to Kia Telluride for
making these interviews happen guys like
and share this video and also keep an
eye out for gate for Abe a huge
congratulations to you we will see you
soon with more Sundance and days yeah
thank you
you